the brothers together William and Harry
what did that mean and tell us what
should we take from this well it was
wonderful to see
how death was unite the whole family and
to see the two brothers together they're
a moving site and these are two
remarkably good-looking men and they're
born we all remember it and we all
remember the other time they walked
behind the coffee and when they were
children and their mother Diana was
being buried so it's so full of meaning
to the public and for us to see them
together again has been hugely
heartening it's been a big Solace to
people in their morning to see the two
brothers together okay well they stay
together will this mend the fences if
ever there was a moment when a
Reconciliation could happen this is
clearly the moment but I think it's
going to take a lot of sort of
imagination and quiet Outreach to make
that happen I mean this is a great
moment for Harry to say I'm not going to
write a book I'm not going to take this
money to do shows I am going to come
back to England I'm going to serve the
new king I'm going to be helpful in the
new regime and for the family to see we
embrace you and give you more
do they want Harry and Megan back here
I really believe that they feel they
need them actually but whether they have
the trust is something else they're so
afraid about Harry's book that he is
writing and the movie that he's doing
and all of the stuff this documentary
unless that stops they're not going to
be able to heal because they're afraid
they don't have to trust they fear that
anything they say will wind up in a book
or they'll wind up in a podcast or
they'll wind up you know spout it out
somewhere so that has to happen before
that reconciliation happens and I think
if he did that I think they would like
him back there's a lot of work to do as
you can see this is an massive
assignment Prince Charles is 73 you know
William is now Prince of Wales he's got
a young family they can't be all places
of course